hello welcome to this game papua 29 from
poland heaven played him for a while but
he's a frequent opponent now in wins
three losses not too bad Jack we had
some I think I mostly had them the black
pieces and we had some chess in games
like that already yep pretty huh he
played a pretty em let's say simple was
pretty simple way but not in a bad way
by this sir very solid here oh you lost
me a 4 it's surprising so think that why
should play b3 to prevent that porn
structure porn structure freeze yeah
he's angling for f4
maybe start with that ok so castles f4 I
can take should be it should be alright
so
recruiting the Bishop to d7 so that I'm
covering a 4 and have at least some
ideas what to what to do with the piece
k see we rooting 91-93 okay interesting
so if for now is an interesting option
yeah let's do it
I was thinking about Bishop g4 but I
just saw that that gives away the pawn
on a 44 probably not that much hmm that
makes this whole idea rather I'm
questionable I cannot play Bishop g4 now
and I can go at least nature for
want to try a five to support and the e4
pawn f5 now is an interesting move k no
f5 set the idea i have f six i also have
93 now after the lightscribe bishops are
traded this was one idea of putting
something on g4 so that i can treat the
the bishops yeah that's do I want to
play I don't think so and five trying to
dismantle on that Center yeah f5 I
definitely have f6 I definitely have to
prevent it's no big question down okay
so I want to check them
93 as a rule that you might might go for
a 93 now I'm going to take tough
position
I think maybe maybe i can go something
like c6 okay after k or c5 c5 is quicker
it's happening quicker for I think I'm
can do that bishops III antiques you Wow
and that I didn't think about it all I
thought this was just bad but maybe I'm
a wrong giving me that activity so what
now some kind of sacrifice on d4 then d5
and let's do that 95 Queen d6 check this
gives me an active position makes it
more difficult for him to check I just I
thought that this this is more difficult
and he plated he just played it okay is
so g5 I can take twice so that's not so
dangerous and think so let's open up
there are tricks now on the third-ranked
that was one idea night night before
simply a queen before simply don't
really see a great reply and Knight
takes e4 and eighty-three Hanks hush
damn nighty for them yeah you would see
that of course yes of course nah mmm
time morning yes I saw the movement at
first but I didn't see that III was
hanging I was such a great position and
now I don't know what what's going on
that's so awful
this was the idea I was just thinking he
blundered again some stuff i canna can
circle here
it isn't even easy to play for him when
she tuned for Quincy to hear check
check check check check check check
check check it was a bit dicey tightly
on check me but it paid off ah I really
didn't want to draw the game I mean I
mean I overlooked stuff but I think here
I'm widest just outplayed completely
yeah taking now this is just just
excellent okay I mean I didn't need to
sacrifice the engine just wants to go d5
like that yeah that's probably better
you know why not the night is not the
bishop is not even very threatening yeah
but it's still not bad yeah that just
sorta church there wow that just should
win somehow rupee aid is winning what
about this now it can go nighty for him
okay that would have saved him Brooke be
a dis winning just intending this and
then take stuff I mean please tie down
that that's such that's a great piece ok
so I went here here and now yeah this is
even the right move wow I'm so bad
technically I can you know I can do
there's an intermediate move and win I
didn't see that so that is just a bluff
just a big Bluff yeah which worked and
now this it's still kind of okay now
look to care for I was lucky that i had
this check ya know this is say he
doesn't after taking it losers just a
chance check check and check so way this
is a winning for black red attack his
King Cashman's to Wed Jan Jan check
check check mate jumped was good to have
them made on the board to some to end
the game okay thanks for watching